hallo mein name ist luca und wenn ihr
euch frage sollte warum ich so
abgrundtief hässlich aussehen das liegt
daran dass irgendjemand von meinen
nachbarn ein rohrbruch hatte und
deswegen das ganze haus den ganzen tag
lang kein wasser hat also wenn ihr mehr
von meiner erhältlichen visage sehen
wollt dann abonnieren einen kanal denn
auch über 70 prozent die das gerade
schon sind kein abonnent das ist
wirklich sehr sehr traurig neben liebe
freunde gehabt bereits haben denn
erkennen sollte die erkenntnis
wahrscheinlich auch am titel denn ich
reagiere heute endlich mal wieder auf so
hard to end in meiner letzten tour hatte
händel action sind wir hier stehen
geblieben
das ist nämlich francesca und das ist
haley und die beiden hatten was und das
hat leider den anderen leuten erzählt
und schauen wie es jetzt weitergeht
weitere scheiße was also tun als ob die
festlegt
m
das gefühl dass diese ganze rebell sache
nur von haley ausgeht und francesca da
eigentlich gar keinen bock drauf was ich
war traurig und hastig gedichte wir
hatten angst das zu sagen aber wir sind
ein paar
warum überträgt sie so krass
er hat einfach umgelegt und ihr müsst
euch keine riesen story doch drumherum
schnallen schnappt euch die seile vom
ski bar workshop- und klettert damit
über den zaun
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ganz kurze frage dürfen da leute sagen
hey ich dachte das ist sonst partyurlaub
ich will das nicht mehr kann man da
einfach austreten gute frage
nach dem ganzen drama heute ist die
stimmung im keller
und natürlich ändern damit alles wieder
gut drauf sind habe ich eine
trainingssession in der sonne
vorbereitet
ja
also ich bin nach sport auch immer
richtig richtig gut drauf vielleicht
denke ich das ja auch davon ab dass dunk
abgekriegt hacken zusammen das war sehr
spannend alles sport die sache ist wir
sind halt immer noch am ende der dritten
folge das heißt eigentlich müsste ja so
rein cinematographie staat eigentlich
müsste ja noch so ein krasser plot
schwitzt kommen oder so ein cliffhanger
dass man unbedingt auch die nächste
folge sehen will kann jetzt nicht sagen
hey friede freude eierkuchen alle sind
cool miteinander kämpfen die freunde
hier enden lassen
das meine ich diese verrückten sind
nicht die einzigen die lahn us hilfe
braucht
was
hi
heißt es es gibt noch andere leute auf
dieser insel oder will hier kommt
notgeile single number nine
dabei wird dieser ahnungslose casanova
das lose leben im resort verkraften was
ja so geht es mir auch gerade und ich
wünsche francesca wird mich auch mal so
anschauen
es gibt also einen neuen teilnehmer
hätte das matchblatt der jetzt komplett
weg bin ich zu spät
was geht denn jetzt helfen vor allem
beim preis muss ich immer an tote
mädchen lügen nicht hängen also ich bin
gespannt was man von bryce so erwarten
kann
vielleicht kommt er jeden abend reiz für
die ganzen leute ich weiß der wortwitz
war es nicht so doll draufgeschlagen da
brauche ich jetzt ein bisschen eis gut
kommen setzen wir uns mal wieder mit ein
bisschen fleisch
ich fühle mich in hohem maße
ich komme aus andré wo ich auf meinem
boot lebe und ist immer was los
schon ziemlich 3 aber wir kommen also an
sich liegt auf einem boot in los angeles
wo kann ich mal vorbeikommen lifestyle
ist ein gut gehütetes geheimnis mädels
magisch an
aha
ich habe auch ein boot lifestyle
er auch wieder wahr mit mir hat man
immer spaß
ich spiele klavier und kann mich in dein
herz und ein höschen sehen und ich bin
der beste
das bin ich den letzten sex hatte ich
gestern ich mache morgens neben einer
auf und denke ich kann kaum erwarten
heute mit einer anderen zu schlafen ja
ich wache morgens neben taschentüchern
auf weil die pollen allergie und sorgt
die kommen nicht so ganz auf ihn klar
die jungs ich noch nicht vergessen von
den regeln zu erzählen also keine ahnung
[Musik]
der wald davor doch nichts
nach diesem fall diesen tag ist das
genau das richtige
hin und her ich feiere ist irgendwie
dass jemand neues mit dazu kommt so von
wegen frischer wind aber irgendwie denke
ich auch da wird mit krisen und geben
damit den streit und wir schauen wir
weiter
die alle voll auf dem abgeben der wird
mir gefährlich
ja baby bitte mal glühbirne wechseln
beim einer lampe hier als wenn die
alle so krass auf den abfahren also ja
safe der sie besser aus als jesus und
das ist glaube ich auch nicht schwer
aber hab da sind echt solche halligen
leute in dieser show jeder in diesem
haus ist attraktiv ihre augen sind so
schön ich könnte sterben jeder user der
alles perfekt jeder junge denkt sich nur
so he was labert der hofer glaubt der
leben wo ich stehe
die mädels sind alle rätsel tag ich habe
dir heut rose mitgebracht
warte mal für mich sieht ja aus wie
sondern wie so ein banker alles klar ich
wollte hier echt schaden uns entschieden
eine person und anwesen müssen durch den
verursacher in voller höhe beglichen
werden lana
die beiden ich glaube die werden jetzt
einen anderen planen die augen fassen
als noch zu beginn der heutigen folge
was weißt du nicht direkt auf so geil
partie male ja wahrscheinlich sind die
auf maria loker kein christen keine
summe
und keine senden und angel war einst das
mit hat mama regeln sind zum brechen da
[Musik]
was man sieht hier schon ganz klar ich
kann das jetzt noch nicht werden wir
müssen jetzt in die nächste folge schon
rein schauen
ich dachte er sei ein moderator
moderator
das ist jetzt nicht aus wie moderator
für mich reist steht auf mich ich weiß
nicht ob die streiten sich auch ums
leben allein auf seinem boot als das
erste
naja handy wenn jemand eine yacht in der
ley hat fühlt sich aber vermuten dass
der ziemlich reich ist
das geld dorthin captain price wird
schnell klar dass sie hier in rauer see
gang erwartet wären diese zwei
leichtmatrosen von ihren reisen auf dem
love boat berichten
ich reise auf dem laufband irgendwie
verstehe ich die neue folge noch nicht
so ganz
ich hoffe ich kann mich sondern öffnet
ich fühle mich erinnern
da ist doch nichts neues dass er den
schritt gehen will und ich hoffe
wirklich dass wonder und schon
zusammenkommen werden die werden so gut
zusammenpassen
francesca habe ich irgendwie im gefühl
dass sie zusammen kommen werden aber
abschätzbar falls du irgendwie mal nach
köln oder sie kommen ganz sicher zu
diesem hengst hier vor euch darauf dass
die frau zu ihm kommt ja solltest du
vielleicht mal goldpreis hatte doch
sofort zu beginnen rugby in der hand
vielleicht solltest du die matte im
offenbacher fragen ich spreche nicht mit
case um harry eifersüchtig zu machen ist
ein job
hier liegt der armen arbeit sondern
dings als wenn das nicht eifersüchtig
kite wollen machbar
francesca ist das heißeste mädel hier
aber dieser buchhalter veruntreut keine
gelder ok sehr gut dieses kleine gerät
nicht gedacht ich dachte zu beginn dass
das ein duft bestäuber wäre und wegen so
ein bisschen lavendel taylor buden der
macht alle hier komplett lana ist der
boss in dieser serie wenn ihr wollt dass
ich weiterhin noch diese serie reagiere
dann lassen unter dem video gern einen
daumen hoch für mich dann schreibt uns
in die kommentare schreibt apfelkuchen
und jetzt befinden uns auch schon im
auto meine lieben freunde wenn ihr
demnächst keine videos mehr verpassen
wollt dann klickt gern kostenlos hier
auf den smiley denn dann werdet ihr teil
der luxus abonniert meinem kanal und
über 70 prozent der leute die sich das
tier gerade anschauen sind auch keine
abonnenten also had und hier ist die
letzte folge tour zu ende verlinkt könnt
ihr euch auch gerne anschauen wo auch
ziemlich lustig
[Musik]